maintenant qu'on a récupéré notre
rapporteur nous allons pouvoir commencer
notre audition est déjà
remercier Monsieur Michel Hiriart
infirmière de Biriatou pas très loin des
Hautes-Pyrénées
qui vous êtes donc président de la
fédération nationale et centre gestion
de la fonction publique territoriale et
Madame Cindy Labory qui vous accompagne
qui est responsable des affaires
juridiques de la fédération nationale et
nous avons en visio madame Magali
Moinard qui est présidente
départementale de la Fédération autonome
de la fonction publique territoriale et
présidente du syndicat national et
secrétaire de mairie section de Vendée
je vous remercie de nous avoir rejoints
par visio et merci à vous d'avoir fait
d'avoir fait le déplacement pour pour
cette audition qui aujourd'hui
porte sur un sujet important pour les
communes et dans le cadre de notre
mission sur l'avenir de la commune et du
maire en France c'est
le sujet du personnel administratif
communal et particulièrement des
secrétaires de mairie si important pour
le bon fonctionnement de la municipalité
alors au cours des auditions des
déplacements que nous avons effectués
nombreux ont été les intervenants et
particulièrement les mers à insister sur
l'importance des secrétaires de mairie
pour le bon fonctionnement des
municipalités ainsi que sur les
difficultés qui se posent pour le
recrutement de ces personnels nous avons
d'ailleurs l'autre jour pu en discuter
lors de l'examen une proposition de loi
de nos amis de nos collègues du groupe
communiste et nous avons déjà entendu au
cours d'une audition d'une audition du
rapporteur le président du CNFPT
Monsieur François de luga aujourd'hui
nous avons la chance de vous accueillir
vous remercions de nous être joints à
nous alors votre
témoignage sera précieux pour nous et
précieux notre mission d'informations
non seulement pour nous aider à mesurer
l'importance du rôle des secrétaires de
mairie mais on est nombreux autour de la
table à le savoir déjà un petit peu en
ayant été maire et aussi pour identifier
les difficultés qui se posent dans leur
pratique quotidienne et pour leur
recrutement et je vais passer la parole
à Monsieur le Rapporteur si vous
rajoutez quelque chose
merci bonjour à toutes et à tous la
présidente ayant tout dit je vais me
limiter dans ce propos introductif en
rappelant effectivement que nous avons à
coeur de traiter dans notre mission
d'information le sujet des conditions
d'exercice
du mandat de maire et donc tout ce qui
peut au proue c'est à dire poser des
questions et parfois limiter voir
décourager on a tous des exemples à
toutes et tous des exemples dans nos
départements faute de secrétaire faute
aussi d'ingénierie faute de moyens voilà
on se souvent on se décourage et pour
nous donc la volonté de réinviter dans
ce dans cette mission la le sujet au
combien essentiel des secrétaires de
mairie plus largement bien sûr du
personnel et des agents municipaux mais
c'est vrai que la pose de secrétaire de
mairie Maryse Carrere l'a rappelé que ce
soit au travers de la dernière
proposition de loi qui a été débattue
j'ai cru comprendre qu'une autre
risqué d'être débattu dans les
prochaines dans les prochaines semaines
déposer par le groupe RDPI et qu'il y a
aujourd'hui de le ministre de la
Fonction publique l'a rappelé des
discussions notamment sur la la grille
de rémunération et puis du statut plus
général des secrétaires de mairie qui
est en qui est en débat voilà je veux
pas être long peut-être vous vous passez
tout de suite la parole et puis bien sûr
après laisser dans un second temps de
nos collègues nos collègues réagir merci
en tout cas encore une fois de votre
présence
le président
domaine que je connais bien puisque vous
faisiez référence à un mandat de merde
j'ai des maires pendant 31 ans maire
d'une commune de 1200 habitants 10 ans
président de l'agglomération donc 19 ans
président du Centre de Gestion dans
cette domaine que je connais
parfaitement bien et parfaitement bien
le rôle de secrétaire de mairie dans les
petites collectivités il faut savoir que
on a exactement les mêmes compétences
que dans les grosses
et les mêmes responsabilités que dans
les grosses
sauf que on n'a pas l'encadrement qui
existe dans les grosses collectivités
[Musique]
à la fin s'il y a une erreur la ceinture
sera la même pour quelqu'un qui fait un
appel d'offre par mois aux parents ou
pas
le rôle de secrétaire de mairie est
fondamental dans une collectivité donc
je sais pas ici que j'ai sans doute trop
insisté c'est le
bras droit du maire
et lorsque le secrétaire de mairie n'est
pas là le maire se trouve dépourvu de
toute
conseil de toute
de toute aide pour gérer le quotidien
et je vais après vous donner quelques
chiffres vous les avez sans aucun doute
mais
on regarde par exemple le nombre des
collectivités
vous savez qu'il y a 31
000 communes
qui ont moins de 2000 habitants
donc ça veut dire que c'est forcément
des secrétaires de mairie
et le secrétaire de mairie si vous
voulez il doit tout savoir faire
parce qu'il fait tout enfin il faudrait
même pas ce qu'on compare au féminin je
vous donnerai les chiffres tout à
l'heure parce que c'est la première
majorité sont des secrétaires femmes
et tout c'est-à-dire ça va du
d'ouverture de la porte de la mer et le
matin jusqu'à ce que tout se passe dans
la journée toutes les
la comptabilité le personnel tout tout
ce que on peut faire dans une
collectivité même de petites tailles
puisque nous faisons mais la même chose
que dans les grosses alors je crois
qu'il faut pour situer le
la situation pour donner quelques
chiffres
et actuellement grosso modo 19000
secrétaire de mairie nous au niveau de
la Fédération nous avons tous ces
éléments là puisque nous je suis
peut-être pas la peine que je vous
présente la Fédération
l'affaire
de l'ensemble des centres de centre
départementaux donc à travers ces
départementaux on a tous les
renseignements et tous les chiffres et
dans tous les domaines de la gestion des
personnels donc
secrétaires secrétaire de mairie donc
comme je vous disais dans le 31.000
communes qui ont moins de moins de 2000
moins de 2000 habitants
94% de des secrétaires de mairie sont
des femmes donc il y a 6% d'hommes donc
très majoritairement des fonctions
des qui sont portées par des femmes
trois catégories
5% des catégories
23% de catégories B et donc
60,5% de catégorie la plupart des postes
sont des catégories C dans cette
fonction de mairie
la moyenne d'âge est plus élevée que la
moyenne d'âge de tous les autres
fonctionnaires territoriaux puisque nous
sommes à
50 50 ans pour 48 heures pour les autres
la moyenne des autres en fonctionnaires
territoriaux
20% sont contractuels
après pour continuer dans cette
énumération
le temps de travail c'est 25 heures
semaine
et les offres d'emploi qui étaient
présentés
c'était 13h semaine
13h semaine qui peut monter à 25 lorsque
c'est agents sont intercommunales
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de secrétaires
de mairie qui sont va plus communes on
appelle ça des plus riches les plus
reconnues
à la fois
le niveau le niveau de formation
universitaire donc 15% collège
baccalauréat à 40%
27% bac + 2
14 % bac + 3 licence et 4% bac + 5 si
vous voulez la diversité des niveaux
pour les secrétaires de mairie
dans le actuellement il y a 1920 postes
ouverts donc sur notre site pour
l'emploi public
et
des offres ont été de 56% en catégorie C
d'ailleurs c'est ça la difficulté du
métier si vous voulez une très très
forte polyvalence
beaucoup de temps au complet
[Musique]
manque de formation je vais y revenir
et puis cette polyvalence des missions
parce que la secrétaire doit tout savoir
faire si vous voulez ce sont des
éléments qui qui contrarie un peu dans
la tranquillité de la fonction publique
et c'est pas ici que je vais je vais le
dire mais il y a manque d'activité dans
la fonction publique en général
et tout particulièrement au niveau des
secrétaire de mairie
donc on a des pistes on a d'ailleurs
beaucoup travaillé dessus ça fait
maintenant depuis 2019 on a une
commission qui travaille assez
régulièrement sur le sujet donc voilà
des propositions
pour essayer de d'améliorer cette
activité de rendre ce métier de
secrétaire de mairie plus attractif et
plus intéressant et ce n'est pas que
l'aspect financier a des choses il y a
bien sûr ça mais pas que
c'est le poste qui qui fait que le poste
est attractif ou pas
voilà si vous voulez certains chiffres
et qui peut-être vont vous éclairer pour
situer le le niveau actuel des fonctions
conduites par les
locataires de les secrétaires de mairie
je continue ou en échange qu'on voulait
madame
on a préparé les réponses aux
questionnaires que vous nous avez envoyé
oui
on va le laisser
je vais laisser la parole à Madame
Moinard si
vous pouvez nous nous faire un préambule
à votre intervention merci
oui
[Musique]
le président national
des secrétaires de mairie
départementale mais aussi nationale
[Musique]
et donc c'est vrai que
j'ai questionné mes collègues de toute
la France
[Musique]
beaucoup sont partis en retraite ne vont
pas se les rendre presque effectivement
et quand on a commencé notre carrière on
était vraiment toute
passionnée
par ce métier atypique de la fonction
publique territoriale
on nous a beaucoup parlé de
simplification administrative depuis 40
ans
c'est pire qu'avant
et le métier de secrétaire de mairie a
bien changé
autrefois on était le premier espion
auprès des administrés et des citoyens
aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'on est le
dernier récent
et donc ce métier complètement atypique
le Syndicat national des secrétaires de
mairie de France que je représente
aujourd'hui
étant en
en disparition
parce que aujourd'hui on a on est dans
un nouveau schéma sociétal aussi
donc c'est un concerne pas que notre
métier ça concerne la société
et donc moi je suis très
surprise et ahuri souvent
des recrutements que sont les élus pour
avoir des secrétaires de mairie
qui
recrute voilà ils veulent une secrétaire
de mairie s'occupe pas du tout de d'un
niveau d'un métier
et donc heureusement vous voyez j'ai
beaucoup de cheveux parce que je me les
arrache quand j'entends
certains maires qui me disent
je trouve personne alors ben là je vais
embaucher une hôtesse de caisse puisque
je suis encaissée et rendre la monnaie
je pense qu'elle sera faire des budgets
j'hallucine
donc première chose pour moi
et les formations
et formation de secrétaire de mairie
mais en parallèle et même en binôme
les élus
pourquoi ça se passe pas bien en ce
moment parce que certains élus alors pas
tous hein j'en connais qui sont très
très
au courant de des problématiques mais
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas été formés
donc ils arrivent en dans leur commune
et c'est l'heure mairie c'est leur
personnel qui est leur école mais ils
font ce qu'ils veulent ils vont
et après on voit beaucoup de démission
beaucoup moi j'ai des collègues que je
suis président national
j'ai des collègues qui sont retraités
qui sont resolicités par les mères de
leur commune après avoir vu beaucoup de
démission
des nouvelles recrues qui ne savaient
pas ce que c'était que ce métier
donc la deuxième chose que j'aimerais
dire c'est que merci et bravo à tous ces
élus qui nous soutiennent
moi ce qui me concerne je suis à la
retraite depuis le premier janvier mais
je continue à aider parce qu'il y a
énormément de secrétaires de mairie en
souffrance donc ils sont en catégorie
c'est
qui
ont donc au premier échelon moins que le
SMIC
compensé parce qu'on appelle la Gifa
sinon t'aurais pas le SMIC les élus
disent ben oui mais nous on n'a pas les
moyens on n'a pas les dotations pour
vous payer plus
et donc du coup
énormément de d'agents repartent dans le
privé
n'en peuvent plus
autre chose donc c'est le mot secrétaire
de mairie secrétaire
moi ça fait
entendre que j'ai proposé
un changement de nom
directeur ou directrice de mairie
alors ça n'a jamais été accepté alors
pourquoi je me suis dit on dit bien un
directeur de crèche
un directeur de périscolaire
mais le fait d'être secrétaire avec des
[Musique]
mots enfin je préfère c'est pas
péjoratif
mais voilà il faut aussi
considérer tous ces paramètres et enfin
j'en ai parlé avec un universitaire qui
écrit un livre sur notre métier et donc
je travaille avec lui il avait
comment dire préparer
il devait venir à Paris
mais bon il a pas pu le dire pour des
raisons personnelles mais on continue à
à communiquer et donc on a parlé il m'a
dit mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec
ce métier
et je dis personnellement nous on s'est
toujours battus
par rapport à l'appellation par appel
par rapport au compétences qu'on doit
avoir tout à l'heure j'ai entendu donc
je pense que c'est un maire
je sais pas parce que je vois pas très
bien en visio qui a dit que dans les
petites communes c'est vrai il faut
avoir les mêmes compétences que dans les
grandes puis on fait des budgets il faut
pas se tromper quand on sait que l'état
civil mais c'est hyper important les
marchés publics la gestion du personnel
voilà et puis je voudrais aussi rajouter
quelque chose c'est que souvent on parle
de stress démographique
vous êtes dans une commune de combien
d'habitants
ça ne sert à rien de parler en termes
moi personnellement quand j'ai commencé
ma carrière oui j'ai commencé dans des
petites communes après j'ai été dans des
villes de 10000 habitants
je suis revenu dans les petites communes
parce que je trouvais qu'on était comme
on l'a dit quelquefois la cheville
ouvrière de tout le monde de tous les
acteurs
et
un jour on m'a proposé un remplacement
donc dans une commune de 2010 200
habitants et j'ai pas osé dire oui mais
je me suis dit bon allez
on y va et en fait je peux vous assurer
que j'avais presque rien à faire
parce que l'école était privée il y
avait pas de service public alors il
faut aussi arrêter de dire de parler en
nombre d'habitants c'est plutôt
quels sont les services publics qui sont
développés dans la commune voilà
merci de votre attention
merci beaucoup madame quand vous parlez
de dernier échelon et de premier échelon
là
c'est pas le sentiment que j'ai
peut-être personnellement mais vous
parlez de quoi de l'accueil du public
dans la dans la commune où
vous avez dit en tout début d'intervent
parce que effectivement
les citoyens les administrer les
électeurs les contribuables de la
commune le premier endroit où ils vont
c'est à la mairie tout à fait personne
ou presque personne ne va au siège de la
Communauté de Communes
voilà mais pourquoi vous dites alors que
que ça c'est quand même encore le cas
pourquoi vous dites que la secrétaire de
mairie aujourd'hui est devenu le dernier
échelon
je vous ai dit que il était considéré le
dernier restaurant alors que pour moi
c'est le premier oui tout à fait
très bien merci beaucoup
après n'oubliez pas n'oublions pas qu'il
y a un problème de salaire
moi j'ai parlé avec des universitaires
et puis des professeurs donc de toute la
France
quand il me dit ben oui on peut
valoriser faire connaître ce métier mais
quand on va leur dire ce que ce qui va
ce qu'ils vont toucher bah c'est sûr
qu'ils m'ont pas rester et après on sait
très bien que avec le nouveau régime
reset voilà donc
c'est ce sont les élus qui décident
donc dans une commune vous allez avoir
une prime maxi et dans une autre on va
vous dire ben oui ce que tu fais c'est
très bien mais on n'a pas d'argent donc
on va pas de payer plus que ça
merci beaucoup merci peut-être une
première série de questions juste avant
de passer la parole
vous posez à nos invités du jour une
première une première question plutôt
réagir à ce que vous venez de dire
Madame Moinard
j'entends effectivement mais même si la
question est s'adresse à tout le monde
où l'affirmation j'entends ce que vous
dites s'agissant de la qualification et
du besoin et on le ressent moi quand je
fais le tour des communes dans mon
département plusieurs phénomènes le
premier d'effet domaines c'est que le
métier a aussi beaucoup évolué par
rapport notamment
au développement de l'intercommunalité à
l'inflation en matière de réunion et aux
besoins de plus en plus fort exprimé par
la population de solliciter l'échelon
l'échelon communal le maire les élus et
donc au premier chef
le ou le ou la secrétaire de mairie en
revanche là où je j'apporte peut-être
une lecture un petit peu différente
c'est que il y a bien évidemment la
question de la formation d'ailleurs
c'est un vrai problème parce que
beaucoup de départements nous disent ne
pas avoir en leur sein une offre de
formation suffisante quand bien même
elle se pondent avec avec les élus et
là-dessus je peux vous rejoindre en
revanche il y a un vrai problème de
ressources moi j'ai beaucoup de communes
alors sans parler de d'avoir recours à
quelqu'un qui est
occupé des fonctions de caissier ou
d'autres fonctions quelle qu'elle soit
mais où on a tout simplement personne je
dis bien personne qui répond
aux offres à pourvoir alors oui je suis
dans un territoire mais c'est pas le
seul qui a une géographie qui a parfois
un enclavement une configuration
territoriale qui fait que c'est pas
évident d'aller dans certaines parties
du territoire mais aujourd'hui on a tout
simplement un problème de de ressources
et si j'osais je dirais quel que soit la
ressource c'est à dire de de personnes y
compris qui n'ont pas eu une formation
ou des expériences préalables de
secrétaire de mérite qui aspire en
revanche à se former là on a un vrai
vrai problème de de ressources voilà ce
que je ce que je souhaitais vous dire et
peut-être que vous réagirez là-dessus
mais je vais passer pour une question
pour d'autres questions la parole à Anne
qu'il a demandé oui merci merci Mathieu
merci Madame pour votre témoignage j'ai
de mon côté été maire et présidente
d'une communauté de communes ce que j'ai
constaté va dans le sens de ce que le
rapporteur vient de dire c'est-à-dire
que on a des difficultés à faire accéder
aussi les secrétaires de mairie ou agent
qui travaillent auprès de nous à des
formations et pire que ça la difficulté
que que j'ai constaté c'est que à partir
du moment où on veut essayer parce
qu'ils sont vraiment de grandes valeurs
essayez de les faire passer d'une
catégorie à une autre ils ont l'acqué de
leur expérience qui ne rentrent pas
suffisamment en compte dans les examens
qu'ils ont à passer et très souvent ce
sont des personnes qui sont excellentes
de façon pratique
à la fois dans l'accueil et l'émission
qui leur sont confiées et qui ne sont
pas toujours capables de rendre des
résultats favorables en tout cas au
passage d'une catégorie à une autre
quand il s'agit de la théorie et on a
beaucoup de difficultés à valoriser
l'acquis de leur expérience dans ces
examens je pense que ce serait peut-être
une piste aussi d'évolution pour passer
d'une catégorie à une autre valoriser
beaucoup plus l'expérience que la
théorie dans ces cas-là je ne sais pas
si c'est votre ressenti mais c'est ce
que nous avons constaté à plusieurs
reprises avec des agents de grande
qualité mais qui n'arrivent pas à passer
l'examen pour monter en catégorie et
évidemment en salaire
oui merci pour pour l'ensemble de ces
témoignages c'est ce que nous vivons au
quotidien quand nous rencontrons les
maires de nos communes et pour ces
secrétaires de mairie moi je pense qu'il
faudrait aller alors je sais pas si
c'est possible vers un BTS de secrétaire
de mairie qui soit vraiment une
spécialité je suis pas sûr que changer
le nom
apportera plus d'attrait mais je pense
que une formation diplômante de
secrétaire de mairie rendrait la chose
plus facile et permettrait d'avoir tout
de suite un salaire beaucoup plus
convenable
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
produire la parole après un amour mais
les yeux
tout ce qui a été en listant abordé par
madame la présidente et par vous c'est
Madame les sénatrice c'est en fait les
propositions que nous portons depuis
déjà un bon bout de temps
et moi je pense que contrairement à vous
peut-être il faut changer le
l'appellation
on a bien changé le secrétaire général
là-bas les secrétaires généraux dans les
grosses collectivités c'était secrétaire
généraux on les appelle aujourd'hui
directeur général directeur général
je pense que ce titre il faut le changer
alors en quoi je sais pas directeur de
service je ne sais pas quoi mais je
pense que le terme madame l'a dit c'est
pas péjoratif mais presque
non je pense qu'il faut changer il faut
changer à notre avis en fait nous les
propositions que nous faisons depuis
maintenant plusieurs années c'est ça
fait partie des propositions
mais il y en a bien d'autres
et ça répond pour partir à tout ce qui a
été à l'instant abordé
par exemple
il faut qu'il y ait un diplôme
en lien avec l'éducation nationale les
universités nous par exemple dans le
département on a la chance d'avoir
l'université de pays pendant de l'Adour
et on faisait on fait par
l'intermédiaire de cette université des
formations pour le secrétaire
et puis il faut une formation
qualifiante au départ il faut une
formation qualifiante et
avec un référentiel de formation par
n'importe quelle formation mais une
formation adaptée à la situation de du
secrétaire numérique on va toujours
encore pour l'instant les appeler ainsi
parce que c'est c'est une fonction qui
est en perpétuel modification vous voyez
bien vous êtes vous voyez comment ça se
passe on dit toujours qu'on doit alléger
mais on complique toujours des choses et
il y a de plus en plus de textes il faut
bien que le secrétaire de mairie parce
que alors après je dis alors c'est pas
pour vendre la les centres
départementaux de gestion mais c'est ce
que terre ont une appui considérable de
la part de sécurité de gestion tous ces
agents ne sont pas abandonnés isolés à
gérer leur commune seule
des dizaines et dizaines de coups de
téléphone arrive dans les salles
départementaux de gestion pour les
appuyer dans leurs hésitations ou dans
leur
chose qui ne savent pas faire
donc une formation qualifiante avec un
référentiel d'origine et une formation
continue
il faut que le secrétaire numérique se
font continuellement et on sait bien
comment ça se passe moi je te directeur
d'une société de trop public et chez
nous c'était pareil quand il fallait que
les gens aillent informations c'était
soit la salut convenait pas et plus
souvent d'ailleurs à l'employeur parce
qu'il a besoin de l'argent et donc ça se
passe aussi un peu pareil et dans ces
cas-là si vous voulez il faut savoir que
dans les 100 départementaux j'y reviens
il y a des services de remplacement de
renfort
de mairie est malade un congé ou absente
mais le maire se retrouve tout seul et
il sait pas comment faire donc les
centres départementaux gestion le
mettent à disposition un agent qui est
un agent de la du centre départemental
de gestion qui est mis à disposition
de la de la collectivité
ensuite il faut
essorer et ça répond à ce que vous
disiez madame il faut instaurer un
système de quota de promotion interne
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le secrétaire
catégorisé ne peuvent pas avoir de
promotion
le service d'ailleurs le simple
principe de quota il faut le changer
si vous voulez le contact actuellement
c'est un recrutement
trois recrutements pardon pour une
promotion c'est à dire que dans un
département dans une collectivité il
faut que vous ayez par exemple trois
rédacteurs de recrutés pour qu'il puisse
y avoir une promotion interne
au sein de la du département alors comme
aujourd'hui les recrutements se font
beaucoup plus qu'en contractuel et que
les contractuels ne rentrent pas dans
ces calculs il y a de moins en moins de
promotion possible dans le département
et là ce que nous demandons c'est qu'il
y ait des promotions hors quota
des formations spécifiques en secrétaire
de mairie qui peuvent évoluer de A à B
sans même de passer de concours contenu
du service qui rend de l'expérience
qu'elles ont
hors quota des promotions internes que
je viens d'évoquer à l'instant sur trois
pour eux
donc voilà aussi une proposition
une bonification d'ancienneté si vous
voulez quand les gens ont une certaine
ancienneté il faut qu'ils aient
possibilité d'avoir une bonification
pour améliorer le leur leur
revenu le salaire tout simplement donc
je pense que j'ai listé à peu près des
propositions que nous relevons ah oui
puis relever le seuil de recrutement
2000 à 2000 parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
plafonné sur le seuil de 1000 habitants
donc
et puis je crois que ce papier je me le
train depuis 20 ans et ses propositions
on les fait depuis l'origine et je pense
que c'est absolument indispensable de
faire quelque chose parce qu'il y a un
vrai besoin
50% des secrétaires de mairie déjà on la
trouve pas
mais 50% des casters en fonction
partiront à la retraite ici 2027
c'est demain donc il faut faire des
choses pour essayer de cette vraie sujet
un vrai vrai sujet que celui de
secrétaire de mairie
oui
c'est très lourd les procédures les
processus de VAE la proposition du
gouvernement c'est celle que nous
faisions également c'est de simplifier
la processus de processus de VAE
notamment pour les agents qui sont
aujourd'hui c comme les présidents c'est
plus de 60% des effectifs puissent
passer en B sans avoir à faire toute le
processus que font les agents de droit
commun qui prend six mois un an et donc
c'est l'une des propositions qui
seraient retenue par le gouvernement
l'idée c'est de d'améliorer le
recrutement mais également de permettre
à celles qui sont déjà en fonction de
pouvoir évoluer
madame renard vous avez quelque chose à
rajouter par rapport aux questions qui
ont été posées ou au constat de nos
collègues
sur le BTS notamment si vous pouvez
brancher votre micro ou votre téléphone
je crois
on vous entend pas
un lot
il faut appuyer sur le zéro du téléphone
la traction par le chalet de toute façon
changera aussi les choses
après on sait très bien que au nom de
la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales de notre
Constitution de 1958 prévoit la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales et du coup
ça veut dire que dans une commune
un maire peut recruter
catégorie
CBA ou contractuel
donc
nous on
en discute entre nous moi je suis le
porte-parole de tous les secrétaires de
mairie de France qui vont également
partir à la retraite et je peux vous
dire un truc c'est que ils en ont
ras-le-bol
et même tout à l'heure j'ai eu deux
collègues donc de départements de
départements différents j'aurais demandé
de si elle voulait apporter leur
témoignage ils m'ont dit non c'est
terminé
depuis qu'on est parti à la presse les
maires galèrent ils recrutent il y a que
des démissions ils font encore appel à
nous et nous on en a ras-le-bol donc
maintenant on est à la retraite voilà et
donc moi je suis à la retraite depuis le
1er janvier j'ai 63 ans
je continue mon mandat de présidente
parce que personne on veut tout le monde
on a les
casquette
et donc du coup moi je pense que le
changement de nom
revalez revalorisation par les salaires
prêt les formations je suis complètement
d'accord mais effectivement quand on
part en formation si on a personne pour
nous remplacer
et c'est pas la peine
et moi j'aimerais aussi revenir sur un
sujet c'est la formation des élus et
est-ce que certains élus savent vraiment
ce que le métier de secrétaire de mairie
alors pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est
parce que depuis 2008
j'ai été sollicité par
les CNFPT à l'époque c'était bon les
Pays de la Loire puisque je suis en
Vendée et
Poitou-Charentes qui est maintenant
devenu un nouvel Aquitaine
pour faire les formations donc
d'intégration en catégorie C
et encore une fois je voulais déjà dit
au bout des cinq jours certains les
agents en savent plus que certains élus
donc là je pense qu'il y a aussi
ici j'ai bien compris
c'était aussi le l'avenir des communes
et des mères dans les années d'ici 2030
c'est ça
voilà donc parler des secrétaires de
mairie alors moi je vais vous dire
franchement
je suis donc dans le syndicat depuis 15
on a fait beaucoup de congrès partout en
France
j'étais pas présidente à l'époque on a
eu des ministres des préfets des
sénateurs
les présidents du CNFPT de l'époque de
décéder et on a eu vraiment des
personnes qui nous avait aidées dans le
sens où
le cadre d'emploi de secrétaire de
mairie qui était passé en catégorie A en
95 ensuite on a évolué en 2003 pour
pouvoir devenir attaché le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup d'élus qui veulent de la
compétence
mais qui
recruteront certainement pas un attaché
elle pourrait être secrétaire de mairie
c'est clair merci beaucoup Cécile oui
merci pour pour vos différents
témoignages peut-être pour
pour redire mais
inévitablement l'avenir du maire dans
les années à venir et aussi lié
à la qualité du travail et de la
relation avec
le lait là secrétaire de mairie je veux
peut-être rassurer parce que je vous
entends madame mais en tout cas pour ma
part et maintenant presque au bout de 12
ans
tous les mers à l'exception d'aucun sauf
parfois incompatibilité d'humeur je
crois quand on passe dans les communes
disent au combien semi tuer et précieux
et au combien sans la secrétaire de
mairie il ne pourrait mener à bien
leur mandat pourquoi ils ont été élus et
satisfaire aux besoins de la population
effectivement quelle que soit d'ailleurs
la taille de la commune on est dans une
on est un peu dans un système de serpent
qui se mord la queue liés je pense
d'abord à la spécificité tout de même du
métier qui n'est pas lié cônon donc il y
a je pense des choses à travailler si on
pense que c'est important des questions
de revalorisation salariale à prendre en
compte mais en donnant bien évidemment
aux élus la capacité de pouvoir
satisfaire à ces revalorisations
salariale mais on a aussi et le
rapporteur le disait des réalités
territoriales c'est à dire que bon et
tant mieux j'entendais ce que vous
disiez sur le centre de gestion de
gestion c'est une réalité mais parfois
ça ne suffit pas c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui moi dans mon département
il y a des communes ou quand il y a un
arrêt de travail plus long que que de
besoin il n'y a plus assez de de
remplacement et à un moment donné c'est
aussi la débrouille pour pouvoir pallier
à l'absence
sur sur ces postes là ou au
renouvellement parce que parfois même le
tuilage entre un départ à la retraite ou
une mutation demandée et le poste
suivant n'est pas possible et avec des
vacances réelles de postes
et je le disais de la spécificité d'un
métier qui même si bien évidemment il y
a la formation même si il y a du lien y
compris entre elles parce qu'il y a
aussi ce système là qui dans beaucoup de
communes est un métier que l'on exerce
tout de même seul et donc c'est aussi un
des aspects du métier donc je crois
comment est-ce qu'on peut réfléchir en
tout cas à essayer de casser le plus et
le mieux possible ce caractère un peu
solitaire du métier et puis vous l'aviez
dit Madame dans vos premiers propos
effectivement sur une plusieurs
décennies au nom de la simplification en
tout cas une complexité de plus en plus
forte et alors notamment moi dans ce qui
me remontait énormément la suite de la
mise en place de la dématérialisation
qui a été par le témoin l'expression
vendue comme une facilité à venir dans
le métier et qui devient une complexité
terrible je ne parle même pas de contre
le réseau marche quand il ne marche pas
etc je parle je n'évoque pas je n'évoque
pas ça bon ça je pense s'arrêter
aujourd'hui donc je crois qu'on a
réellement un manque de personnes
disponibles de difficulté aussi de
personnes qui
n'ont pas forcément envie d'avoir trois
quarts d'heure de route pour pour qui
donc trouve d'autres métiers c'est aussi
des réalités et sur les évolutions j'en
parlais avec quelques secrétaires de
mairie
là aussi on rejoint une autre difficulté
je vais lui dire avec beaucoup
d'élégances mais de deux personnes qui
aimeraient avoir de la mobilité
peut-être échanger mais qui n'ont pas
quoi pour avoir un poste plus important
ça veut souvent dire soit aller à la
ville soit aller à l'intercommunale au
siège de l'intercommunalité et qui
souvent se trouve dans la ville et donc
voilà
une promotion pour trois quarts d'heure
de plus aller et retour finalement on y
renonce et on reste effectivement
dans dans le métier qui est le sien mais
moi je voulais quand même redire je
pense que voilà les mères ils essaient
de tout faire alors j'entends peut-être
qu'il y en a qui sont pas bien formés
mais oui recruter aujourd'hui ça devient
difficile et à un moment mais moi j'ai
des mères qui me disent je prends je
prends ce que j'ai sous la sous la main
mais parce que sinon et vous le disiez
très bien monsieur sinon la mairie le
matin n'est pas ouverte et donc la
première des choses c'est déjà de
pouvoir avoir quelqu'un et puis dernière
question quoi réflexion plutôt
je pense quand même que la
dévitalisation de l'échon communale ces
dernières années
a aussi
susciter des intérêts dans un métier qui
bien évidemment quand la commune est au
cœur de la vie et de l'action publique
quand les élus sont valorisées qu'on y
pense situation de crise politique comme
aujourd'hui et bien les agents
municipaux le sont d'autant plus et
en tout cas ce sont des métiers qui
attirent donc voilà moi je crois qu'il y
a plusieurs points parce que on peut
faire toutes les meilleures formations
qu'on veut mais quoi je le redis s'il y
a pas les gens de toute façon
on bloquera donc oui pour des revers les
organisations salariales bien évidemment
à l'état aussi je le terminerai de
donner les moyens aux collectivités de
pouvoir les satisfaire parce que là
encore moi j'ai plein de mères ils
aimeraient bien les payer plus
quand à la fin de l'année tout le monde
fait le budget bah il va malheureusement
bon oui des fois on peut faire deux
trois petits petits plus mais mais ça va
malheureusement pas plus loin même si je
crois que tout le monde reconnaît que le
travail est largement sous payé au vu du
caractère indispensable et de la qualité
du service rendu tout au long de l'année
merci une réaction peut-être
oui
en plus ces personnes par rapport au
déplacement que vous évoquez dans
l'instant madame c'est que ces personnes
non seulement sont attachées au poste
nous sont attachés à leur commune
pas partir ailleurs
et c'est pas ils vont pas avoir
l'intention d'aller ailleurs il cherche
même pas aller ailleurs ils veulent
rester là parce qu'ils sont on a tout le
monde c'est les enfants du de la commune
sur les élus simplement parce qu'on est
pas là pour parler des élus mais moi
j'étais président des maires du
département donc je connais bien les
élus alors évidemment il y en a qui sont
peut-être nommé que d'autres mais très
très globalement les élus assument leur
fonction dans de bonnes conditions
alors ce qui a complètement changé par
contre dans une vingtaine d'années
lorsqu'on interrogé à 20 ans il y a eu
une enquête qui a été faite par la
Fédération à l'époque
sur quel était le comment situer la
gestion du personnel en maire qui est
arrivée dans une commune sur 10 postes
sur 10 sur 10 possible le budget les
routes et bâtiments communaux bref et le
personnel huitième sur 10 le personnel
ce qui n'est plus du tout le cas
ce qui n'est plus du tout le cas les
élus aujourd'hui prennent conscience
qu'ils ont les mêmes responsabilités que
l'employeur privé et qui sont obligés
d'en tenir compte alors après on parle
de formation
vous savez dans les dans tous les
départements l'Association des Maires
des
départements de l'association
départements
font de la fonction
et d'ailleurs il suffit de regarder au
début des mandats il y a énormément
d'élus qu'il faut réfléchir la formation
alors c'est le maire directement ou
c'est la joie alors c'est pas c'est le
budget des fois c'est l'urbanisme qu'on
doit presser donc il y a des formations
qui sont qui sont suivis et on peut pas
non plus demander à une main en mer
d'une petite commune de 200 ou 300
habitants de passer son temps non plus à
se former pour pour diriger la commune
dans d'où la nécessité de ce binôme
absolument indispensable dans une
commune le maire et son secrétaire
si je peux me permettre pour aller dans
votre sens et dans ce qui vient d'être
exprimé ce que disait Cécile Guy Herman
aussi mais je pensais quand même quelque
chose qui est à prendre en compte c'est
on a aussi une évolution j'en parlais
tout à l'heure dans le contenu parce
qu'on a cette strat intercommunale qui
nécessite aussi un lien entre la commune
l'intercommunalité qu'on a de plus en
plus de de réunions notamment avec les
services de l'État avec
j'allais dire toutes les tous les
satellites qui qui
existent autour de de l'échelon de
l'échelon communale et puis ne jamais
oublier qu'à l'exception même si ils
sont nombreuses et nombreux des élus qui
sont à la retraite ou n'exerce plus de
profession il y a aussi la difficulté à
conjuguer vie professionnelle et
activités d'élus et ce qui fait parfois
de la veut même de mer qu'on a pu
rencontrer c'est compliqué aussi de
trouver le temps avec le de mairie pour
parfois échanger concerter on se croise
et on prend plus ce temps nécessaire
parce que tout est devenu très très
chronophage donc je enfin voilà je
j'apporte juste j'atténue peut-être le
sentiment en tout cas que peuvent
ressentir parfois juste titre les les
critères de mairie d'un manque
d'attention ou d'un manque de
connaissances des élus mais je pense que
et vous l'avez dit c'est une
complémentarité absolue aucun élu a
fortiori quand il est maire d'une d'une
commune de moins de 500 ou moins 1000
habitants et que ça n'est pas ni son
lien avec son activité professionnelle
ou sa vocation première il y a beaucoup
beaucoup surtout dans dans le paysage
institutionnel aujourd'hui et dans
l'inflation normative de choses à
apprendre personne n'est omniscient et
que forcément il y a besoin de se juste
équilibre de ces deux jambes que sont
d'un côté la secrétaire de mairie et de
l'autre et de l'autre la mer mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que moi je je fais
bien aussi les propos de de celles et
ceux qui ici ce soir disent que les mers
sont quand même très attentifs et en
tout cas revendique le besoin d'avoir
des décrétaires de mairie et plus
largement même des agents qui puissent
les accompagner on n'a pas parlé du
sujet juridique mais c'est vrai que la
place des questions juridiques notamment
dans dans le quotidien des des
secrétaires de mairie va va grandissant
et cela aussi c'est un autre sujet parce
que de plus en plus les élus sont
exposés à des risques et bien sûr
partager aussi avec avec les secrétaires
de mairie qui sont là pour les pour les
accompagner dans ces dans ces questions
là
oui une autre question que je voulais
vous poser il y a cet entretien annuel
qui normalement se fait entre le maire
et l'employé la personne secrétaire
numérique que vous avez l'impression que
c'est suivi est-ce que c'est l'occasion
pour ces secrétaires de mairie de dire
de faire part de leur doléances
d'essayer de de faire avancer les choses
et les relations entre les élus et
elle-même vous n'avez aucun retour
là-dessus normalement c'est c'est une
obligation et peut-être aussi le moyen
de s'expliquer beaucoup plus sur les
difficultés rencontres l'un et l'autre
d'ailleurs et puis et puis aussi de
faire évoluer et je pense que c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'il faut que
l'on creuse aussi
nous on fait une plaquette qu'on appelle
l'horizon tous les tous les hommes
pour jeux des tas de questions c'est
pour ça qu'on a des éléments à notre
possession puisque nous interrogeons et
recharge le cabinet privé d'ailleurs à
faire ce boulot et qui interroge
plusieurs milliers de collectivités
enfin collectivités ou fonctionnaires
dans le dans le National c'est une
question qui pourrait être effectivement
posée
on n'a pas posé pour le son
après vous savez que l'entretien se fait
de niveau à un autre mais c'est vrai que
s'il y a que le maire et la secrétaire
il y a pas d'intermédiaire
sur d'éventuelles
expériences que vous avez de syndicat de
secrétariat
pour plusieurs communes
est-ce que c'est quelque chose
d'efficace voilà mutualisation nous on a
ça sur notre territoire ça d'ailleurs
c'était très avant-gardiste parce que le
premier date des années 60 donc elle est
une époque où il y avait peu de
syndicats mais donc des communes qui se
sont fédérées de telle sorte que comme
vous le dites justement le public des
secrétaires de mairie est
essentiellement féminin au moment des
grossesses des difficultés rencontrées
parce que les enfants à la maison était
malade et que la secrétaire est obligée
de rester au chevet des enfants tout
simplement qui est une permanence
assurée pour d'autres communes donc
c'est un pool de secrétaire qui
qui se déplace et ce que est-ce que
c'est quelque chose éventuellement que
vous préconisez ce que vous avez un
retour sur ce genre de syndicats et de
mutualisation de moyens entre plusieurs
communes puisque ce sont les rares
syndicats qui n'ont pas été menacés de
disparition au moment où il y a eu un
grand nettoyage
pour répondre à votre question on a vous
avez une particularité enseignement
c'est qu'il y avait pas de service de
remplacement avant le 1er janvier 2023
c'était l'un des seuls CDG je suis élue
en Seine-et-Marne d'accord je le sais
donc il y avait pas de service en
placement depuis le 1er janvier 2023 il
y en a au cinéma avec d'ailleurs un pool
secrétaire de mairie qui qui est en
réseau et je pense qu'ils se sont
inspirés de du syndicat que vous évoquez
dans les autres ce centre de gestion
dans les autres départements ça se fait
via le centre de gestion et un réseau
des secrétaires de mairie comme il y a
un réseau des DRH donc il se réunit
peut-être tous les mois tous les deux
mois et quand il y a un remplacement
assuré ça se fait via le service de
remplacement après il y a aussi des
expériences de sein de secrétaire de
mairie mutualisée au niveau de
l'intercommunalité
ça s'est développé depuis les schémas de
mutualisation notamment depuis la loi
2010 il y a quelques intercos qu'on
connaît qui ont fait l'expérience de
mutualiser il y a eu une forte
résistance au changement je le dirai
dans certains de certains départements
je pense en Bretagne notamment il y
avait une expérience assez forte de
mutualisation des postes de secrétaire
de mairie et c'est vrai que la mise en
réseau nous on l'appuie c'est ce qui
permettra de renforcer l'expertise parce
qu'elles sont expertes mais elles sont
pas forcément expertes toutes sur tous
les sujets et c'est grâce à la mise en
réseau qu'elles peuvent se former et
avancer ensemble
se passe même on l'a vu à la communauté
d'agglomération d'agnaux c'est qu'ils
embauchent un nombre de secrétaires et
il demande à chacune de se spécifier
dans un sujet que ce soit l'urbanisme
que ce soit les questions juridiques
plus fines la question environnementale
et question plutôt comptable voilà pour
pour permettre aussi d'asseoir cette
forme de polyvalence et de capacité à
répondre à des questions qui sont
parfois fines et qui malheureusement ont
plutôt tendance à se multiplier
qu'elle est en diminuant
est-ce que
du côté des centres de gestion vous avez
des initiatives qui remontent
particulières pour pallier la pénurie
prévisible de secrétaire de mairie
s'il y a des initiatives particulières
je sais que c'est des g65 par exemple à
fait l'année dernière une formation
spécifique de de volant d'une trentaine
de secrétaires de mairies ou entre 20 et
30 personnes qui
spontanément se sont présentés est-ce
que vous avez des
exemples un peu innovants aussi pour
aller peut-être motiver motiver les gens
et pallier cette pénurie et ensuite la
dernière question que je vous poserai
c'est si vous aviez une seule
recommandation à retenir
quelle serait la plus importante à
retenir pour pour justement susciter des
vocations et
avoir ce secrétaire de mairie
opérationnel comme on les a aujourd'hui
et qu'on en aura peut-être pas demain
[Musique]
de laisser répondre aussi dit sur la
première partie parce qu'il y a des il y
a des initiatives locales et on va vous
en donner quelques unes un mot sur le
service remplacement au niveau de son
départementaux de gestion
c'est un outil
c'est un moyen exceptionnel je dirais
pourquoi pour plusieurs raisons la
première celle qu'on évoque depuis qu'on
est là c'est-à-dire remplacer quelqu'un
qui est pas là et le maire ne peut pas
attendre pour continuer à gérer sa
commune de pas avoir de secrétaire donc
il faut trouver il faut trouver une
solution donc
c'est un jeu en se forme
une
avec la pluie des conseils qui reçoivent
de ses collègues du voisinage ou et
surtout des centres départementaux de
gestion
et à
99,99% des cas
ils sont recrutés
et rend nos services il se forme et son
recruter
ça c'est absolument je regarde ça depuis
toujours c'est vraiment une situation
assez remarquable au niveau de service
emplacement en forme mais
malheureusement on en a pas suffisamment
c'est vrai alors quand pour répondre à
la question pour poser madame c'est que
quand par exemple quelqu'un est absent
dans une collectivité mais si c'est
quelqu'un qui est à temps plein mais on
avait à quelqu'un
et en attendant que voilà parce qu'on a
pas suffisamment de personnel à mettre à
disposition pour tout le monde Cindy
pour les
initiatives évidemment beaucoup de son
de gestion a mis en place que vous
évoquez comme dans le CDG 65 il y a des
formations avec des personnes qui sont
recrutées notamment via le Pôle emploi
dans quasiment tous les centres de
gestion avec une formation là on a un
petit souci de désengagement de Pôle
emploi dans certaines régions qu'on
essaie de traiter avec le gouvernement
pour financer là la formation et
d'ailleurs il y a un centre de gestion
qui a eu une idée assez intéressante
c'est le centre de gestion du Cantal
pour pallier justement le désengagement
de Pôle Emploi ils se sont rapprochés de
la CCI et du coup ils ont mis en commun
des formations de notamment d'assistante
de direction assistante commerciale du
privé avec la formation de secrétaires
de mairie avec des formations communs
comme ça elles peuvent aller découvrir
et les métiers du public et les métiers
du privé elles ont des modules
spécifiques évidemment secrétaire de
mairie prise en charge notamment par le
Centre de gestion mais certains modules
en commun avec avec des avec un vivier
de personnes destinées assistantes
commerciales ou assistante de direction
on a également des soins de gestion qui
se sont rapprochés des GRETA
et des CAP EMPLOI pour former des
personnes en situation de handicap pour
au métier de secrétaire de mairie donc
on a plusieurs centres de gestion qui
travaillent sur ces questions et on a
également le centre de gestion de
l'Isère qui a mis en place une
prestation de conseils recrutement
spécifique sur le métier de secrétaire
de mairie puisque les centres de gestion
ont la mission d'aide recrutement mais
là ils accompagnent vraiment sur le
recrutement permanent des secrétaires de
mairie avec une phase mise en phase de
tutorat certaines secrétaires qui sont
tuteurs de celles qui sont en phase de
recrutement et une expérience aussi
importante on parlait tout à l'heure du
diplôme on a le premier diplôme
universitaire de secrétaire de mairie
qui n'est pas un diplôme de métier de
l'administration comme on peut voir mais
vraiment secrétaire de mairie
l'Université de Lorraine avec le Centre
de Gestion de Meurthe-et-Moselle
donc on vous a listé ces expériences
dans le document qu'on a rempli
si vous m'autorisez je vais repartir sur
ce que vous avez dit tous les deux sur
l'échéance 2027 avec 50% des secrétaires
qui partiraient à la retraite ce qui
veut dire aujourd'hui que on a devant
nous quatre ans on va dire trois ans
pour pallier à ça et ça c'est une
influence maximale sachant qu'en
parallèle on peut se dire on va avoir
aussi dans un certain nombre de
départements la crise de l'évocation
chez les maires et qui qu'on risque de
voir arriver sur les municipales de 2026
alors certains seront ravis de dire on
va fusionner chacun aura sa vision des
choses sur le sujet mais l'urgence qui
est devant nous à la fois sur à la fois
les élus et
de recrutement là fait que quel est
selon vous peut-être une initiative
nationale de ce point de vue là et de
l'état puisque c'est une urgence absolue
qui devrait être gérée avec le ministère
de l'intérieur de ce point de vue là et
la fonction publique puisque malgré tout
c'est eux qui sont aujourd'hui aussi
enfin intérieur et collectivité en tout
cas mais qui sont
aussi puisque pour le bon fonctionnement
de notre pays j'ai envie de dire si on
ne réagit pas de façon
massive et de façon
urgente plus urgentissime d'ailleurs on
va se retrouver dans cette situation là
et quelque part en 2026 aussi deuxième
question échéance puisqu'on aura
vraisemblablement des maires qui vont
arriver qui n'auront jamais été lui
avant ou qui seront bien pour la
première fois et vraisemblablement des
secrétaires de mairie qui vont arriver
qui n'auront pas d'expérience aussi et
donc de ce point de vue là quel serait
les initiatives à prendre à l'arrivée de
ce nouveau binôme qui potentiellement va
faire jour vraisemblablement au
lendemain de ces élections
un seul point et lequel
c'est compliqué
nous nous on a cinq propositions
s'il fallait les comment dire
les prioriser
je crois que c'est la formation
parce que c'est de là que la formation
et c'est promotion hors quota c'était
permettre
à ces secrétaire qui sont déjà en
fonction
de pouvoir les faire passer en catégorie
B c'est une reconnaissance et évidemment
le salaire avec
je pense que le reste s'est changé
d'appellation à mon avis il faut
absolument le faire mais bon c'est pas
ça qui va changer de but en bleu qui va
donner plusieurs activités à la fonction
la formation qualifiante ça c'est sûr
et leur montrer qu'on est qu'on
s'intéresse à ces secrétaire de mairie
alors madame a raison
pour des fois pour plusieurs communes
lui dire qu'il faut partir s'assurer des
formations de quelle durée on n'a pas
encore
travaillé
de faire ces plusieurs semaines un
plusieurs fois par une seule fois parce
que sinon donc la formation je conserve
indispensable et permettre à aux
secrétaire qui sont déjà en fonction la
possibilité de les faire promouvoir hors
quota ça va se savoir et entière voilà
un métier qui a de l'avenir puisque on
va pas rester calé à notre catégorie C
du jour de l'entraîne en fonction
jusqu'à la retraite il y a une évolution
possible dans le métier ça va savoir et
ça va intéresser les gens parce que dans
les cinq propositions que nous faisons
les deux prioritaires de mon point de
vue c'est la formation et la promotion
possible des
CV c'est pas tellement du bien
sont à la limite capables de passer un
concours ou quelque chose mais forcément
ceux qui sont catégorisés donc pour
seulement les aider peut-être pour une
autre initiative aussi on s'est engagé
avec le CNFPT sur la démarche métier
territoriaux pour promouv la fonction
publique territoriale et on a sorti un
guide petite plaquette de 8 pages sur le
métier de secrétaire de mairie qu'on
promeut dans les universités dans les
auprès des anciens onisep et on va
tourner un clip prochainement avec des
secrétaires de mairie et des maires pour
donner un petit peu envie aux gens de
déjà de connaître le métier et de venir
travailler dans les territoires je pense
que c'est très important enfin ça même
donnerait l'occasion d'un plan de
vocation enfin un appel à la vocation
enfin je pense que c'est un plan
national qui nous fout là d'une certaine
façon c'est une initiative
oui ça j'en doute pas mais c'est pour ça
que je fais un petit piège mais il faut
quelque chose en tout cas
[Musique]
de l'université ils savent même pas
qu'il y avait des emplois territoriaux
je savais pas donc on a évolué mais bon
il faut faire plus
juste même un petit il y a plein de
jeunes aujourd'hui qui se réinvestissent
dans la politique la vérité c'est que
souvent le premier pas dans dans rural
en tout cas dans la dans le milieu de la
municipalité c'est nous c'est les
comités des fêtes qui après avec les
responsabilités arrivent sur les équipes
municipales mais ça pourrait aussi être
présenté comme un tremplin pour devenir
et lui après parce que on apprend au
final le métier en première étape aussi
pour certains en tout cas
[Musique]
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour pour ces
éléments et qui vont être importants
pour pour notre mission merci d'avoir
fait le déplacement aussi
depuis bientôt merci madame moignarde de
Magnard depuis depuis la visio et merci
pour votre témoignage et votre votre
expertise
merci à tous de votre invitation de
votre écoute
mais je reste quand même très dubitative
par rapport à tous ces discours
parce que depuis 1989 existe
en arrière avec vos propositions que je
salue
et
[Rires]
celles qui sont à la retraite et celles
qui vont partir à la retraite
ras le bol
alors si vous voulez on voulait faire on
vous laisse faire et par contre tout à
l'heure j'ai entendu une intervenant
dire mais on prend ce qu'on a sous la
main
tant que c'est compliqué à comprendre
c'est pas possible dans les périodes de
pénurie malheureusement
c'est pas possible de dire ça ça veut
dire que les secrétaires de mairie tout
compte fait on peut prendre une
secrétaire de garage
une hôtesse de caisse une coiffeuse et
on prend ce qu'on a sous la main c'est
le constat c'est quelqu'un qui a dit ça
je sais pas qui
on peut pas continuer comme ça voilà
c'est un constat qu'elle fait moi je
j'assume ce que j'ai dit mais je peux
vous le redire après on peut le réel
peut ne pas nous plaire et d'ailleurs si
pour certains on fait de la politique
c'est parce que nous pensons que dans le
réel qui s'impose à nous il y a
certainement des choses par l'action
publique à modifier pour permettre aux
gens de vivre mieux chacun dans sa
position politique mais si on ne fait
pas le constat d'un réel tel qu'il
existe mais comme on voudrait qu'il
existe pour nous en tout cas faut faire
autre chose et donc ça peut ne pas faire
plaisir d'ailleurs je ne crois pas que
ça les premiers qui ne sont pas
satisfaits ce sont les élus les élus ne
sont pas satisfaits quand ils n'ont
personne alors que il y a un poste à
pourvoir et qu'il y a des besoins et que
donc il faut un moment donné pouvoir
recruter mais dire cela c'est en rien
des valorisant c'est pointer aujourd'hui
la vraie difficulté qu'il y a à pouvoir
recruter effectivement des
personnels qu'il faut et les former et
donc oui il finit à un moment donné on a
des recrutements et comme vous le disiez
je pense ce n'est pas la faute des élus
c'est pas un manque de volonté de la
part des élus c'est pas une incapacité
des élus à faire des bons recrutements
ce sont des élus qui eux aussi sont
confrontés à un manque de demande pour
pour voir ces postes là voilà c'est
c'est une autre objectif c'est de ne pas
se satisfaire de cela et par je crois ce
qu'on a évoqué les uns les autres et en
continuant de cheminer ensemble
d'apporter des réponses pour que
effectivement la situation qui fasse je
n'ai pas de secrétaire de mairie
qu'est-ce que je fais et bien ne se
reproduisent pas et que tous les mers
quel que soit la strat de la commune
puisse être accompagné au niveau ils
doivent l'être
très bien
on vous entend pas
appuyez sur le zéro oui
pour terminer je voulais quand même dire
que le questionnaire que j'avais donc
adressé à mes collègues aussi
c'était plutôt l'avenir du maire et de
la commune
parce qu'en fait on a parlé à 90% que
des secrétaires de mérite oui c'est
normal parce que
on a jugé on a jugé indissociable
du service public
c'est ça fait longtemps que ça dure
tous les collègues me disent voilà on
est dans la case ils ont pas voulu nous
expliquer que maintenant il se
débrouille et puis après
c'est vrai que c'est
et puis voilà
mais moi je j'ai été très content de
tout les défenses merci à vous encore
une fois moi j'ai commencé à travailler
à 18 ans j'ai 63 ans et je continue à ce
métier que j'ai adoré ça se sent madame
ça se voit
avec des élus qui étaient
surtout m’intérêt général
merci merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
votre voyage et merci à vous et bon
retour bon retour chez vous et merci aux
collègues qui étaient nombreux ce soir
au collègue féminine surtout merci